the Senate version of a sweeping
Republican tax overhaul could be headed
for final passage this week senators
voted last night along party lines 52 to
48 to start the debate on the bill no
Democrats support the package president
Trump repeated at yesterday's rally that
working Americans not the wealthy will
benefit most from tax cuts Nancy Cordes
is following the debate on Capitol Hill
Nancy good morning good morning Senate
Democrats do not agree with the
president's assessment and neither do
independent analysts they say that under
the Senate plan the biggest share of the
tax cuts and the most permanent
individual tax cuts actually go to those
making more than a million dollars a
year people who make less than $75,000
would actually see their taxes go up
within 10 years a problem that
Republicans say will be fixed down the
road now this bill is still being
revised to appease some GOP deficit
hawks they're discussing a provision
that would eliminate some of these tax
cuts if the GOP proposal doesn't grow
the economy as planned some Republicans
say no they'd rather see automatic
spending cuts in that scenario rather
than tax increases senators Marco Rubio
and Mike Lee want to lower the plants
cost by bumping the big corporate tax
cut back up by two percentage points
using some of that money to pay for an
even bigger increase in the child tax
credit and the bipartisan Joint
Committee on taxation does say that
under this plan more than 60% of
Americans would get a tax cut of at
least $100 in 2019 Republicans Galle are
hoping to hold a vote on the plan by the
end of the week thank you very much
Nancy